autre décision en provenance cette fois
du ministère de l'Intérieur Charles
pascoy vient de demander à tous les
préfets d'examiner au cas par cas la
situation des parents étrangers dont les
enfants sont français s'agit-il d'un
assouplissement des lois pasquis sur
l'immigration réponse avec Anne
poncinet leurs enfants sont français
parce que nés en France mais les parents
eux sont en situation irrégulière et du
fait des lois pasquis ils ne sont ni
expulsables ni rgularisable un Casset
administratif contre lequel ils se
battent depuis plus d'un an à bout
d'argument si d'entre eux ont commencé
il y a un mois une grffe de la fin ses
parents étrangers d'enfants français
avaient d'abord reçu le soutien de
nombreuses associations qui au cours de
manifestation demandait la
régularisation globale des dossiers puis
il y a quelques semaines c'est Daniel
mitteran qui rendait visite au grevistes
de la fin enfin vendredi dernier
François mitteran avait promis au
dirigeants de l'association plein droit
qu'une solution serait trouvée avant son
départ de l'Élysée aujourd'hui une
circulaire invite donc les préfets à
étudier au cas par cas les dossiers en
souffrance et pour les associations qui
les soutiennent c'est un premier
pas je crois que le cas par cas
aujourd'hui ça s'imposait par rapport à
l'urgence de la situation mais qu'en
réalité énormément aujourd'hui de
familles étrangères sont brisées
séparées fragilisées et que donc c'est
il faut revoir l'ensemble de ses
dispositions parce que je pense que la
France ne sera jamais plus elle-même
sielle n'est pas capable de revoir la
situation des hommes et des femmes qui
sont sur son sol depuis des années les
grévistes de la fin eux craignent que
ces circulaires ne soi pas suivis des
fait ils ont décidé de poursuivre leur
mouvement en attendant d'avoir leur
titre de séjour en
main